what were you saving no gamma you just
want to do five minutes cuz you want to
do slow sensuous kisses me I want I've
seen you kiss paper
[Music]
no no you know you're like it's
different now I'm a sort of regular
monthly video together so if you haven't
already watched we've done two videos
over on their Channel
and they definitely definitely finish
watching this so maybe and I are going
on tour for our podcast I'm a little
frantic trying to get out all the
pertinent information at the top of this
video so I don't forget let me take over
yeah we're doing our tour this might get
weird in seven cities the link is below
maybe we're coming to your town it's
gonna be fun it's gonna be half podcast
half like stand-up scripted stuff check
it out what else are you doing also
Hannah has a book that is a nice book
Wow you can just put my drink right I'm
calling an audible on these shenanigans
because I have to talk to you about
audible listen up Amazon Prime members
for a limited time you can sign up for
an audible membership and save 66% off
of your first three months that's a
total of $30 off that's like getting
three months for the price of one three
Gungans for the price of one in this
video see how it connects you pay $4.95
per month for the first three month and
after that it's 14.95 per month offers
valid from July 1st to July 31st all you
do is go to audible.com slash grace or
text grace to 500 500 and here's the
best reason that you should do it is
because one of the three Gungans that's
a 2 that's a 3 now hannah has a new book
called my drunk kitchen holidays how the
saver and celebrate the year and it is
available for pre-order on audible she
will read the entire book at you to you
with you so support that beautiful
little sprout
and her holiday cookbook my drunk
kitchen holidays go to audible.com slash
grace or text grace to 500 500 if you
thought this was clunky get ready for
the rest of the video we shot two really
fun videos on their channel and in
classic grace pelvic fashion
I was dry four ideas before we got to
this so I tweeted out asking you guys
what you would want to see lots of ideas
about getting drunk and high in various
situation I think we're past that I
think we've all matured I think we've
all leveled up a little bit let's
[ __ ] this weekend I got a tweet from
marble muse that says lipstick kiss
print paintings of each other that
sounds like things we need to do
individually first put on lipstick then
we kiss then we can print then the
Papuan
okay my interpretation was I'm Way more
available for us to do right here right
now like this in real time without
making out with each other it's like a
nonchalant
I don't know here's the deal the one
thing I love is getting information from
you guys on the internet and then not
looking it up at all to find out one if
it's already been done which I'm sure it
has been or to what the actual
parameters of what this thing means this
is my interpretation lipstick kiss print
paintings of each other oh look I got a
new idea of what she meant what we
lipstick kiss paintings of each other
you just said exactly what this tweet is
with different inflections you know what
I think it means let's do it my
interpretation of this is because
lipsticks come in so many different
shades that we can do some portraits of
each other using only an emphasis on
four four tracks of each other that we
can only use these colored lipsticks
that I bought very quickly at a CVS and
we can only use our mouth
as our paintbrushes what else would you
kiss with grace helbig Wow so I put all
of our names in a hat and I choose a
name of the other person we're gonna
have three to five minutes you use these
lipsticks to make a portrait of the
person that you choose and then we're
gonna present our art to each other and
the class you guys and just see you know
where our artistry and creativity takes
us it has to be through kissing it you
can't just use the lipstick no no your
mouth is the brush so I can do different
styles of kissing like and also like
okay kissing less the short answer is
yes I'm gonna let you guys choose if you
choose yourself just put it back until
you don't get yourself don't say it out
loud who do you have because we're gonna
guess who had who well okay okay I'm
gonna put five minutes if we get done
way too early
we will reassess I know I need to like
get themselves in an artistic space more
than they are now I just need to know
why ma'am I did that with her hair I
twisted it and put it back so it's not
in their hair so you either like
aerodynamically moving she was doing
bobbing for apples she'd do the same
thing unfortunately have a shorter
haircut that allows you more dexterity
in these sorts of competitions I got a
really cool hat you can begin okay okay
wait oh yeah playing colors to make my
image look like a amateur that was the
longest I've ever done no I feel too
intimate with this piece of paper right
guys you haven't even gotten to the
gentle kisses yet we gentle over here so
oh wait I wish this color would show up
Wow
[Music]
okay we have 20 seconds left no good I
know a lot of artists like Banksy don't
show you exactly how they work but we
like to be transparent that's what we do
here just like you what do I look like
right now yeah I got you you and your
lips have a nice like glossy shine to
those that would anyone like to go first
I would Wow go ahead other heart okay
I approve an age because my portrait
it's very incomplete okay I got a little
too detailed focus and I'd like to
reveal to you justice I'm shocked but
that looks really great wait why because
you gave me my bat your Condor no that's
beautiful my hair I wish my hair was
made of kisses also like II didn't do
your eyes or nose so maybe looks like I
took something cool like it yeah you
could sell this on Etsy you guys want to
get this at one of Greece memory shows
or just or do you just want it mimicked
I'll go next okay we can all go down
from here right
and then I was like I'll just go her
Jersey roots you can see the brown bear
your eyebrows the blue circle that's
good though that you could conveyed some
feeling in their aggression yeah I did
it how much better than I did
I feel wait I got him I got bad I
started with there and then I realize
the blonde ever gonna work so I used
blue but then I tried to do a tie-dye
t-shirt oh and then I put you on a penny
board for some reason because it just
seems like that the activity you would
like to do so then I try to turn this
into like a helmet because you love
safety I think it got away from me Oh
better at a penny board great I mean I
don't forget to get your tickets for
this make get podcast store down there
and preorder how this book and go check
out the videos on their channels that
should be up by now art is you know not
subjective at all whatsoever that's I
don't know and no no thank you
you got some dollars on this challenge
it's not expensive but I got twenty four
dollars worth of CVS points after buying
all this so there is no way you got
twenty four dollars of extra bucks well
I bought these because they were
supposed to be five dollars off each
okay that's really good actually yeah
the most extra bucks I've ever gotten
was nine no I'm the thing the saddest
part was that he announced to me in
front of everyone how many dollars I
saved how this as far as I hang out with
two people who pay attention to that
stuff